i'm trying to think of all of the things
i've like read and watched that's come
out this year
i can hear the dialogue yeah
i mean it's it's been a lot i i i'd have
to like go back through because it's a
lot yeah yeah okay like movies movies
has been not so much movies has been not
so much but i've barely released any
movies because yeah it's still a
pandemic yeah i mean actually they've
really geared up recently
i've watched a lot of movies recently it
feels like all the big movies yeah
they're just starting to come they're
just starting to come out now because
they were supposed to come out like a
year ago
yeah like like i know like there's been
some new mcu movies that i just haven't
watched do you care about the mcu
anymore you know i heard eternals was
like bad yeah
really bad really bad yeah i don't think
i'm gonna watch it not that i ever gave
a [ __ ] about the mcu but i don't you
know the mcu now it's like okay now you
need to prove to me why i should care
again now that it's over like
like
to me it's like i i don't think they can
just coast off the success of the
previous entries i think yeah sure we'll
get like the the series that everyone's
gonna go and watch like doctor strange
and all that stuff yeah that's gonna be
cool but if they're trying to sell us on
new characters it's like okay how are
you gonna sell us now that there's no at
the moment there's no big thing that
we're planning towards yeah right like i
wanted you to watch like changji for
example but also i had no like incentive
to go out and watch it you know i heard
it was amazing though like a lot of
people said it was really good but also
but also i thought it was really good
but but again like you kind of like the
same thing where i'm like okay i'm not
gonna lie a little burn out on the whole
superhero thing yeah yeah like the only
thing i'm really excited for superhero
wise uh is uh batman with robert
pattinson uh just because i'm looking
forward to that i love robert patterson
i think he's so [ __ ] good in
everything i like the batman movies yeah
all the way moves are chill but like
because they've they've cast like what
everyone thought was quite an unusual
choice which like robert hatson is
definitely uh well i mean it's unusual
yeah have you watched any of his stuff
that he's been in like the some of the
indie films that he's done i've seen one
indie film that he was in i forgot the
name of it but what was what happened in
it
roughly do you remember oh no no okay
because it was literally the first indie
film he did after the twilight yeah so
he kind of obviously like he can't have
a bad rap from twilight because he was
like before he wasn't really he was
typing caster yeah yeah and yeah and he
i love interviews of him like [ __ ]
on time no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no he [ __ ] hates hate he
hates him
you know he wouldn't i can only imagine
what it felt like where he was like i am
a serious actor who trained
professionally went to like the most
prestigious [ __ ] in the uk yeah and now
i'm here doing a [ __ ] half dead
vampire who barely emotes yeah right and
then he went on the whole kind of like
indie film uh like series where he just
did so many indie films he was doing he
tried to change his image yeah and then
he was doing really good artistic films
some of them were amazing yeah uh the
lighthouse was amazing if you haven't
watched that really amazing i highly
recommend it it's got a what's his name
um
yeah wonderful ryuk you may know him
my favorite word
and so far i've just loved watching him
and so i feel like he's probably gonna
do something interesting batman that i'm
like a lot of type casted actors though
have like gone down there like daniel
radcliffe went down like a massive indie
film round like because you know
everyone just knows him as [ __ ] he's
still busy [ __ ] kissing and [ __ ]
everyone on set yeah yeah
i went on like i went on like a massive
binge of like daniel radcliffe like
indie films and like some of them are
[ __ ] amazing like kill your darlings
is an amazing he did a lot of odd films
and he did a lot of uh
yeah theater stuff yeah because he was
like i think it was quite a big thing in
the uk right after harry potter ended or
during harry potter he did something
that required him to be like naked yeah
like a horse or something yeah yeah yeah
i remember in the uk the tabloids were
like don't know red kip's a porn star
now and then like people are already
trying to drag him because obviously
british tabloids are like the [ __ ]
worst on earth yeah they're so bad but
like drama youtubers you know which is
just imagine if every newspaper just
turned into keemstar yeah
basically
like it's it's weird because i'm
remember when someone like leonardo
dicaprio was seen as the teen heartthrob
you know the titanic the titanic guy you
know and how hard he had to work to like
change that image even though even back
then i'm in aging right
no no but even back then he was like a
hell of an actor and i don't think like
i don't think people gave him enough
credit at the time i mean i remember
like it's i mean i remember it was like
a prevailing joke where just like if you
ever feel bad about your day remember
that you have the same amount of oscars
as leonardo dicaprio you know i finally
got one he finally got one he finally
got one but now like now you see him
aged up and like
he couldn't be more different you know
he didn't age up he glowed up he [ __ ]
bought colonel did you watch um
superhero actually quite enjoyed
recently
the suicide squad not suicide squad oh
the suicide the suicide squad there's
two suicide squads there's another yeah
yeah yeah there's a new one that
released on hatred so the one when
i know james gunn yeah by the way
really good really really good really
really fun uh idris better than the
schneider cut oh my god it's like did
you watch the snyder cup uh yeah it was
awful i wanted to die
it was terrible
what is it my name is katana that means
sword or something in japanese that's
like the best line
is real line yeah one of the swords like
her name's katana it means sword in
japanese
um yeah it's something along those lines
that could be misquoting uh yeah it was
really good idris alba is the main
character in it and idris alba is just a
pleasure to watch always
always just kill it and john cena's
really good in it uh
he plays like a psychopath justice man
it's so good so yeah
he plays a character called like
peacemaker is it yeah yeah and
he's just like a [ __ ] murderer but
he's just like it's all for peace it's
all for peace
and so he's very funny really good in it
really really really it just it works
and then he's getting his own movie now
peacekeeper really yeah john cena is
just like [ __ ] hilarious in every
role he's really good yeah he's he's a
really good he's actually a good actor
yeah yeah yeah
yeah the whole film was just really good
really fun really well made is it like
is it like a standalone thing or was it
gonna yeah stand alone completely uh
as far as i know they're not doing a
sequel i don't know though
because nowadays you just can't have a
superhero movie without someone being
like oh this is uh this is playing
like cinematic universe i think i think
it's just a just go watch it i guess you
the other characters like peacemakers
getting his own thing but in terms of
like this thing dude you can just watch
it suicide squad cinematic universe
starting turn your brain off like it's
really good does it have anything to do
with the original no because i watched
the original and i'm just like this is
the most five out of ten movie i've ever
seen in my life it's in the same thing
so like it's like the same premise but
good
yeah it's a reboot but like just watch
it it's one of those films where like
you don't have to pay up much tension
all right it's just turn your brain off
a really good time for two hours at
which point are we just gonna not be
able to track which new like superhero
franchise is like which ones are reboot
which ones are building on to like the
cinematic universe
it's the new yorkers
is the new batman film is that part of
the original is that something separate
or is that following on from like the
zack snyder batman i'm so [ __ ]
confused
as much as batman is a superhero i don't
watch batman movies as a superhero movie
it doesn't feel like a superhero movie
to me yeah
i kind of agree with that well that's
the dark knight trilogy yeah because
that kind of like i feel like that kind
of redefined yeah you don't get the
where as you watch a marvel movie you
know exactly what you're getting yeah
and like to some extent you do with
batman as well but for some reason when
batman goes down that route though they
do it in like kind of like a campy
tongue-in-cheek right like yeah you know
like the george clooney like batman
around because it because it's just like
with batman movies it's like i i always
think is this like a batman movie or a
batman in the you know dc universe movie
right like where because if if they make
batman in a movie um that has to
integrate with the rest of the dc
universe there are some rules that you
need to like acknowledge you know
whereas with where if it's about
standalone batman movie you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah it's
just a [ __ ] he's just a [ __ ]
weirdo
like you say like what the [ __ ] is he
doing
why is this this man's hobby
but i mean yeah i really enjoy the
batman movies and uh
again like yeah like i said when it
comes around i i i don't feel like it's
the same thing and
when i watch a marvel movie you kind of
they've kind of gone to this formula
recently that is kind of really boring
and unpredictable where it'll be like
all right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna have the thing with the with the
really big stakes and we'll bubble crack
a few jokes along the way of course
we're a family friendly movie and so now
they've all turned into the pseudo
pseudo-action comedies
in some aspects like thor uh for
ragnarok really like led the way for
this i think after thor ragnarok like
every single marvel movie had to be
funny i think it was always like that
it was always it really turned up to 10.
it was like you watch the like first
avengers and you're just like oh
everyone's got quips everyone's got
something funny yeah but like it just
like fall ragnarok was more of a comedy
movie than an action movie did you watch
it yeah of course i watched it it was it
was more jokes than [ __ ] plot points
in that thing yeah but that that's also
what i liked about it yeah i did too and
but i i'd argue i'd argue like so it's
like guardians of the galaxy which came
before thor right i i feel like it's the
same kind of vein but i just felt like
everything started doing that yeah i
feel like everything's just kind of
ramped up yeah i'm not sure if the
newest marvel movies are then like do it
or not because i haven't watched them
obviously apparently eternal just has
sang like i think thought ragnarok is
just that formula is because title ytt
was directing it yeah because that's
basically his formula right yeah yeah
yeah but like yeah
was like tired of doing the old like
shakespeare thing yeah yeah well every
single every single goddamn marvel movie
now has the funny guy in it but someone
who's like just there to crack jokes you
mean iron man well yeah i don't know he
doesn't crack chat i mean there's
someone else like oh gosh geez i don't
know what's going on
terrible joke to do i don't know
in general like most of them like oh
yeah who gives a [ __ ] about ant-man
i think i give a [ __ ] about ant-man okay
that was a fun movie it's like the d
tier of [ __ ] marvel characters right
like
like literally no one gave a [ __ ] about
him well i feel like that's what they're
doing now with like the newer superhero
movies where like like some of them some
of them you watch and you're just like
oh you're really scraping the bottom of
the barrel that's why
that's why i just like don't care about
marvel movies anymore like literally the
last good marvel movie i watched was
probably like iron man 2.
yeah
we finished him infinity war was just
did you watch that no oh it's such a
good film like infinity wars actually i
only know about the film through
is that the last marvel movie you've
watched
probably oh my god
well maybe like wait for the
sledgehammer
no i just don't watch the [ __ ] marvel
film song because i just don't care
about superhero stuff
like
wait what wait uh [ __ ] deadpool was
marvel right
technically it was marvel but it was
also fox own but it doesn't feel like a
marvel film yeah yeah
so i don't know yeah well yeah because
it's kind of it's in the x-men universe
yeah it's in the yeah yeah yeah yeah
those those lines yeah but the x-men
universe has gone to [ __ ] too yeah yeah
yeah the x-men universe is fun
which sucks because i really enjoyed the
x-men stuff well logan was like the best
film the last best yeah yeah i agree and
then every subsequent film with the any
anything to do with x-men it was just
terrible yeah yeah yeah i mean
i don't i don't even even think x-men
was like that great of a franchise
because they've always struggled with it
they've always struggled to they've had
like some good films in the x-plane
franchise but if you take a franchise as
a whole and later in front of me it's
like
i think there's more bad movies than
there are good movies in the x-men
franchise especially the new stuff